in a lengthy interview with ITV ahead of
the release of his Memoir Prince Harry
has spoken about rowing with relatives
his family working with the media
against him and clarified he doesn't
think the Royals are racist rivalry
between Prince Harry and Prince William
may not come as a surprise but now we
know the competition between the two
brothers extended to their facial hair
Prince Harry had to ask the queen for
permission to keep his beard for his
wedding which she granted but that
annoyed William because she'd previously
told him to shave his own bid off then
there's the Press Harry's disdain for
the media is well known but now he says
that some relatives have colluded with
them by planting and leaking stories to
trash him and his wife Megan even goes
so far as to say that some of his family
are in bed with the devil I.E the
tabloids Harry says he wants
reconciliation with his family and for
him forgiveness is a hundred percent
possible but so far there's still been
no official response from the palace